they have become a symbol of this crisis
pensioners queuing at Greece's banks
trying to get money it's a scene
repeated every day across the country
older people are allowed to take out
just one hundred and twenty euros a week
many have to go to several banks to get
it some machines are already empty while
they wait they mull over this crisis and
well over their future yeah it can't get
any worse I'm afraid about what will
happen if we don't get an agreement
literally afraid I hope we find a
solution I can't imagine we'll be
isolated from the rest of Europe that
would be tragic I hope all parties reach
an agreement so we can have a brighter
future and so we can get to our money
because they're holding it from us a
short distance away another man also in
desperate need of money Alexis tsipras
met with his cabinet to hammer out the
final details of his reform proposals
once finished they have to be approved
by the Greek parliament then sent on to
brussels by tonight leaders from across
Greece's political spectrum a rallying
round fully aware of the gravity of the
situation they face hello descrip we are
all united in the endeavor to secure the
place of Greece in both Europe and in
the eurozone legitimately to go together
hope you worry but many believe that if
see press is to win support in Brussels
his proposals will have to include more
austerity the queues outside the banks
may get smaller but the hardship people
face